When building a successful e-commerce
business, the first thing that you have
to realize is that the best customer
is a customer who keeps coming back.
And so as we look at Teespring,
the people who do really well
on our platform are people
who've been able to build a brand
with our buyers on Teespring.
And been able to bring them
back over and over and
over again to be able to
purchase more and more products.
And the best thing,
what you can do to actually ensure
that is really invest
in customer service.
And really invest in sort of answering
any questions that your customers have.
And kind of really making
your customers feel that
you as the kind of e-commerce platform,
or
as a product owner,
actually care about what they want.
And so it's really easy to kind
of think about, all right,
let's optimize the purchase flow,
let's kind of cut costs where we can,
let's offer the cheapest price.
But at the end of the day, what's
going to bring that buyer back again is
the customer service and the actual end
to end experience that you offer them.